feel things hey guys today I'm on set
for Elektra when Dyna girl watch when
Dyna girl calm and today I want to show
you a ways that you can have fun on set
first way is to drink a green tea thing
that you got from a coffee truck earlier
fun another way try to have a bowel
movement in your trailer tell ghost
stories by your trailers fireplace Tara
Reid is on Twitter I know someone that
notes the one that works and props on
that show Ghost Adventures
I got followed by the band Oh town on
Twitter the other day ghost give Brett
the third ad and insincere compliments
hey Brad cool walkie-talkie shake wish
all the crew members heads
oh now that now that you know it's the
new Angry Birds make old-school movie
puns pay this production is sold school
it still uses a tape pick delicately and
beautifully to your lunch you do sprays
your food once you finish good job food
you do that correct confusing signs
that's not correct explore different
areas of set that's coal admired the
shrubbery ooh
if Peter a compliment Peter you look
great chair have some epiphanies about
the entertainment industry that woman
probably auditioned to be the model for
this photo she has a family she gets
diarrhea she's human
dance because you're wrapped and there
you go there's how to have fun on set I
don't know if this pertains to anyone
but it got me through today I don't know
Ichigo two-electron diner girl calm to
catch more info and updates about this
project another way try to have a bowel
movement in your trailer Oh a shower fun